the Department of Health and Social care
and the Royal College of Nursing have
just issued a joint statement regarding
pay talks let's bring you that statement
right now the statement reads the
government and Royal College of Nursing
have agreed to enter a process of
intensive talks both sides are committed
to finding a fair and reasonable
settlement that recognize the vital role
that nurses and nursing play in the
National Health Service and The Wider
economic pressures facing the United
Kingdom and the prime minister's
priority to half inflation the talks
will focus on pay which of course is
significant terms and conditions and
productivity enhancing reforms the
health secretary will meet the Royal
College of Nursing on Wednesday to begin
talks the Royal College of Nursing will
pause strike action during these talks
that's the end of the statement so these
talks are going to begin on Wednesday
that's exactly a week of course before
the next bout of strikes were you to
begin now on Wednesday the 1st of March
at 6am for 48 hours the last set of
strikes by the nurses was on the 6th and
7th of February so these talks a
significant step to try and preempt or
prevent that next round of uh strike
action from the nurses let's bring in uh
John Craig who's able to join me now
from Westminster and John a significant
step in particular a line in there that
says they will talk about pay which of
course has been something that that has
been so so hotly debated over the last
couple of weeks on one level of course a
step forward if these strike actions is
avoided on another level I wonder
whether the government will Theory
opening a little bit of a can of worms
all sorts of sectors will want similar
talks on pay
well this looks like a breakthrough
doesn't it because uh up to now of
course has been absolute stalemate with
the uh RCN uh blaming the government and
saying they weren't prepared to have
meaningful talks about pay but I think
for most people the most significant
sentence in that joint statement is the
last one that says the Royal College of
Nursing will Paul's strike action during
these talks now as you've mentioned wolf
but major escalation of the RCN strike
action was due to take place next week
now last week the Royal College of
Nursing announced that the strike next
week would affect more than 120 NHS
trusts across the country far more when
previous stoppages and the two-day
continuous strike would be the largest
in the NHS history according to the
Royal College of Nursing and uh the
union claimed it would cause enormous
disruption to Services running longer
and involving more people Pat Cullen the
RCN general secretary said and what was
significant about that strike action it
was it previously the strikes have been
just day shifts for 12 hours those in
January December and February but this
strike action that was due to take uh
next action apart to happen next week
was due to run for 48 hours from 6 a.m
on the 1st of March and the union said
this time that it would involve nursing
staff and emergency departments
intensive care units Cancer Care and
other services that were previously
Exempted so everything a lot now hinges
on these talks involving the Royal
College of Nursing of course there's
been a huge pay gap between what the
Union's been demanding an increase well
in advance well ahead of the currents
inflate station rate which is 10.1
percent
um and the government is not not
prepared to go anywhere near that so we
will see obviously if there is a
breakthrough tomorrow when they actually
get around the table as yet it's just
the Royal College of Nursing not the
other unions representing the ambulance
Cruise the GMB Unison and unite it's
just the Royal College of Nursing but it
is highly significant and potentially a
very important breakthrough especially
given that that very serious strike
action plan for next week is now paused
by the Union
for that in Westminster